[Musique]
je pense que je devrais demander si bhl
et aussi parce que je sais où les
abordons cette crise morand
la magie a pas de miroir est ce qu'il ya
une personne qui a déjà prouvé dérive à
toutes les implantations du pharo
respect depuis sa naissance
personne alors à vous confirmer les
résultats libéraux cherchent les jambes
et 6 centimes à venir nous naissons et
grandissent en plus avec les
préoccupations opus formule mathématique
de vous avertir la plus hot in et
explore toutes les possibilités pour
devenir des solutions dans les autres
finissent par les élèves et leurs
professeurs
assurez vous m'appelez chacune on est
donc en train de parler de ça mais pour
faire les complications
de 42,6 des jumelles sur la carrière
mais je vous pose une question est ce
que vous me prouvez veut plus aller ce
n'est de toute façon il ya les caméras
il s'était mis à dos les mêmes
contraintes
[Musique]
je suis là mais jamais de ma mère de mon
père en tout cas jusqu'à pau
[Musique]
beaucoup de personnes aimeraient être à
ma place mais j'aimerais qu'elle mettra
la leur en réalité en tant que dernier
né vous êtes considéré par nos parents
comme nouveau né à qui on veut
la subvention est là toute la
surprotection rien ne change côté un an
aux enfants c'est comme ça n'a pas
d'explication deschaseaux j'ai passé
toute mon enfance dans les jupons de ma
mère quand nous avions des élites et à
la mise au jeu mais l'impression que le
l'espace ou lui précisé que l'air se
confiner que j'allais surtout aidé par
des
je regrette toutes les raisons de vous
étaient calmes et in fine il collait et
j'ai moi-même été harcelés parce que je
suis formée du port et ont confisqué le
ballon juste à l'âge de 15 ans je
devrais partir du cocon familial pour
des raisons scolaires elihu désormais
devant donald r nouveau ma mère le monde
entier s'attendait à ce que je refuse de
mon année vous dominez part j'ai déjoué
les pronostics comme le pm face au maroc
la plupart des nations de liste je suis
parti au collège de cette partie du
public à l'université aimé antheunis et
les cours ont meilleur restaurant la
cuisine mon coeur net la machine à
écrire et est passionnée assure toujours
la canonnière que je t'aime que je suis
souvent en me taire la victime devient
championne devant on a une compétition
organisée par l'ambassade des états unis
et c'est ici que mon lancement 10 mois
je me suis rendu compte que la vie or le
monde un gouvernement que vendre
l'appartement
il y avait énormément de choses à faire
que mes mots et va voir pour me toucher
les coeurs des changements que je peux
désormais affronter les regards et les
projecteurs la france je suis la valeur
ce délai trop chaque jour mon ami van
dijck envoyée
il a seulement oublié parce que ça fait
une semaine qu'on ne s'est pas levée
mais ajuste de fallu envoyer le lien
d'inscription à cette fameuse
compétition
et moi je me suis dit vous pouvez me
rendis n'en est rien
un an plus tard je vendais open concept
qui pourrait parler d'elle
c'est le groupement civique sans grande
précision mais plus aujourd'hui est une
organisation non gouvernementale qui
peuvent pour l'autonomisation des jeunes
la liberté d'expression la promotion du
théâtre par plus tard et les paniers
second des couches mais la victime il
dirige au jaune puis les deux personnes
qu'elle encourage même le père l'avait
dit la pythie vite j'ai regroupé sur les
deux ports et à la maison des esclaves
entre déclaré devant une foule de
touristes venus du monde entier apprend
à monter le coût de ses années
d'université
je ne m'y attendais
nous avons parfois tendance à croire que
nous sommes qu'il est champion de france
pour découvrir la face cachée
[Musique]
et parties vont penser les leçons les
plus importantes redevenir sortir de ma
zone de confort subir le choc culture
vivre des expériences possibles heureuse
car les gens en plus vite comme gmail ou
qui vénère comme leurs aïeux faisait
même pas pourquoi je pense que les gars
vous êtes fait je suis plus belles
informel alors je vais propose avis pour
savoir qui joue les interprofessions et
quelle image
j'avais envie que les gens gardent et
pour l'anecdote
bonjour monde les personnes aujourd'hui
a dit jeudi la régie personnes seules
escales ou non confessionnelle en ces
trois dernières années j'ai un fils
partir
il s'agit d'une décision qui effraie la
majorité des personnes par peur du futur
par mois de 20 à 25 ans j'ai déposé ma
lèvre donné aussi à la seule chose dont
j'ai moi même assez la proposition
d'emploi parce qu'elle respecte
l'environnement le travail est toxique
est hostile
mon établissement à 25 ans je devenais
productrice de posséder le premier top
shop et les béthunois qui est une
plateforme de promotion de la liberté
d'expression et qui permet au jeu de
traiter des sujets urgents et yoro
gérard il appert espérons men droit vers
20 heures et vingt ans
il est évident que le monde et ses
habitants ne descend jamais les
incroyables
sur les bords mais vous l'avez la
possible de leur rappeler l'homme peste
jeunes et des personnes
là le devoir détruire ce que vous avez
environ un an après la création de mon
blog de données virtuels aura fait vous
avez ce soit comme au quotidien de la
presse et bill hall a plagié un de
behzad après rappelé déposé aux
autorités de régulation
ce quotidien y répondra et conformément
au code éthique le néocolonialisme
j'ai appris à lâcher prise et il ya un
conseil que je bordelais sur ce point
c'était le font jamais je n'ai jamais
pensé à ma carrière
schubert sur des promesses de personnes
qui sont généralement pas aussi bien
à mieux aimer aimer au delà que toute la
vie marine que je partage avec l'amour
de ma vie ma vie de femme a repéré à
venir des émotions et je dirais pour
saquer pour temps et mon énergie avec
personnel connu
j'ai déjà fait recaler à des personnes
que je rencontre est pour la première
fois parce que dans leurs yeux j'ai vu
qu'ils en avaient besoin
mais dites-moi est-ce que vous alliez
que le calais a le pouvoir de renforcer
notre sentiment de style pureté et de
confiance et a aussi le pouvoir votre
jeu c'est mon secret pour rester
jose reyes alors vous allez me dire
qu'une personne timide de ferrades tous
sens et c'est vous qui avez raison
selon certaines recherches pas
imaginaires dans cette fois scientifique
à un tiers de la population mondiale
était pro et je fais partie de cette
minorité qui représente une énigme
les gens autour de nous ont l'impression
de poupée est en réalité et ne
connaissent que nos masques nous avons
c'est en apprend que nous sommes qu'il
est bon parce que semble alors que la
plupart du temps les analystes france
est prévenue
la seule manière bon de savoir pourquoi
vous hésitez et pourquoi vous vous
séparez avoir son propre école et vous
apprendre quelles que soient les ventes
internes que le lieu où ce diorama vous
en sortir et aller leur diplôme qui
n'est délivré dans aucune université vol
- et c'est ce diplôme qui marquera le
début novembre histoire dans les rochers
je commence à avoir la sensation que
l'espace reprise
lunaire se profile que je suis beaucoup
parti c'est moi qui vais pas mes amours
j'aimerais vous dire une chose une seule
chose est savoir vous vouliez samoa
oubliez tout ce que je n'aime pas
oublier ce que je n'aime pas c'est en
réalité c'est vous qui avez la russie
c'est vous qui avez répression
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]